that's one two thirty and so will will
leave doom there for now maybe do a bit
of know do we want to talk about more
Bart actually so I bet that doom 2016
would probably be Oh K ish envy are
assuming okay assuming that you can
handle VR in the first place I think
doom would be kind of okay in VR because
it does have the proper field of view
adjustments and whatnot but that said
like the speed of it undoubtedly like
it's going to be sort of pushing the
limits of kind of what what VR would
really be if you're on the edge of a VR
doom would be a no-go but I don't it's
difficult to sort of explain myself
why because VR VR is weird there's okay
so there's an episode there's a there's
a script that I've got fragment of that
I've been working on for like almost a
year now it's all about VR and the
gutter like the concept of of the gutter
and end of presence and the fact that
virtual reality is is proprioceptive ly
far more intense than any other media
because there is no there is no gutter
there is no space between between
audience and and experience that be when
so so right now like let's say even if
you have a giant ass like 32 inch screen
like let's say you've got a 32 inch
screen sitting right in front of you on
your desk and I got 30 32 inch 4k and
you're running doom at 120 FPS 4k and on
this giant
a screen right in front of you that's
that's pretty intense and it's taking up
a significant amount of your field of
vision but at the end of the day there
will always be that space that that
awareness space between your body and
the screen there will always be
something at the edge of your periphery
no matter how big you make the screen
you know your peripheral vision goes all
the way like out to almost 180 degrees
it's like your your field of vision in
absolute terms is like 170 degrees
175 177 to 5 degrees now granted the
detail that you can see where the edges
here is like nothing like it's basically
just motion but there is an awareness
there just and even just that little bit
of it's like okay there is world out
here there is world down here I can see
my hands I can see my keyboard even if
they are not in high-definition because
they're at the edges of my vision
they're still there they still exist and
virtual reality takes that space and
eliminates it even when virtual reality
is is fairly low res the increase in
intensity by losing your body is is so
different that that even fairly minor
things and in VR end up being just that
much more intense and now the main
challenge in in telling people about
this or in them is that it's like it's
really hard to demonstrate without
putting a headset on someone's head and
just being like okay check this out
we'll talk about it afterwards like
we'll have a debriefing when this is
done and so so the the the space of
talking critically about virtual reality
feels so abstract right now because even
when you do a good job at explaining it
it's only explicable to people who are
essentially already kind of familiar
with it so you're really going in and
you're telling someone like ok what you
have just experienced here's what's
going on there and yeah so it's it it
really does need an a dimension of
personal experience before before it's
really useful to put words to all of
this but but yeah I mean it so for those
of you who are familiar with it with VR
or those of you who can at least
visualize the experience like it is the
loss of the body the loss of the edges
the loss of the gutter of the of the
distancing space between between self
and screen between between person and
page that that no other and this is a
thing that no other medium shares so
it's it's really quite it's special it's
it's different and actually wait I was
supposed I just remembered that I was
supposed to respond to someone about
having a sit-down this weekend about
virtual reality particularly VR video
because so now now here's the thing
here's the other part here here's the
other part so I'm going to give you a
preview here's the other part of the
video is that when we say virtual
reality where we're really talking about
a whole cluster of different things that
you'll hear people talking it's like oh
yeah we're doing a VR project and now in
this string
because we were just playing doom we all
sort of understand it is like via the VR
what we're talking about is game and an
directly interactive experience but
there's a bunch of different related
mediums media that that all use shared
technology but they interact with it in
very different ways so you have you know
you're using the VR headset but VR video
stereoscopic VR video a mono scopic VR
video spherical video is a very
different experience and has very
different characteristics and uses and
engagement profile than a VR game and
but people they just use VR as as the
terminology when really VR is is the
technology the words I shouldn't even
say VR is the technology the headset is
the technology and really we're talking
about so when we talk about VR we really
mean the headset so it be in the same
way that we talk about like oh it's it's
a television thing that it's like
because it goes on a television but at
the same time like a console game goes
on a television and that's vastly
different than a VHS cassette and all of
this stuff kind of cut just like it
becomes very challenging to talk about
it's like well what do you mean and for
me in particular looking at the way that
they interact looking at the way that
the differences in what people are
willing to tolerate and what they engage
with and why and how differently between
spherical video and virtual reality
games to me I find that just to be like
immensely fascinating because you so so
here's one of the major challenges with
spherical videos that spherical video is
really people can really only seem to
tolerate it for short periods of time so
it's it's good for
it's good for sort of short news
segments short documentaries
walkthroughs limited experiences like
like a rollercoaster you know something
you're looking at about five to eight
minutes as kind of the ceiling on what
people will tolerate at least at the
moment because people aren't used to it
and this will probably change in the
same way that you know the pace of the
pace of editing today is much different
than it was even back in like you know
nineteen eighty purely because audiences
have since you know since the invention
of cinema audiences have become more and
more and more and more and more used to
the language of the medium and so you
can push it farther and people don't get
lost because there they they speak it's
they speak the language and so they're
able to keep up and so right now there's
almost no one who's actually fluent in
the the experiential language of wearing
a virtual reality headset and so the
things that they're willing to tolerate
the things that they can tolerate are
much more limited so in spherical video
because you lose your body and you lose
your ability to control the world around
you in any way other than pivoting
around the point you know you can't even
lean forward or lean back and and have
it feel like that you can look up you
can look down you can look left right
like you can look around but you can
basically you become a pole with a head
on top of it and and nothing you know
nothing else can do anything to to the
world if you want to lean forward and
look over something you can't
and so that loss of the body gets worse
over time like it has a it has a
compounding impact on the psyche over
time and so about eight minutes right
now is the limit sort of what people are
willing to willing to tolerate and you
need to cut quite slowly you need to be
very judicious with your cuts they need
to
and you really need to limit how much
you're expecting people to like turn in
terms of where you want to show them
stuff and the the major challenge there
is if you're thinking about it like okay
a five to eight minute engagement length
like who's going to take a three pound
actually I think I think fully loaded
like four pound uh VR headsets with a a
lot of cables that big around coming out
of the back of it like it'll like if
you've seen like the vibe like if you've
actually seen the vive and the the
oculus like in action like they've got
this fat umbilical coming out of the
back of them this it's as thick as a
loonie it's you know as big around as a
link like this big old umbilical coming
into the back of it like they're bulky
they're awkward and it's like who wants
to go through the effort of getting that
on to watch a five-minute mini doc about
you know water protests and it's like
well while no one like the the
complexity and the barriers inherent to
the technology that it's like okay it's
big its bulky it's awkward so you don't
just want to throw it on that is is in
direct conflict with the duration for
which people are willing to tolerate the
content so the challenge there is like
okay well then how do you deliver like
if spherical video is really only
tolerable to people in short bursts but
the technology is so bulky that people
only kind of want to go through that
effort for either a one-off sort of
specialty things like if it's an
installation in in a museum or if it's a
demonstration at a trade show or
whatever at a convention like it's like
okay that's kind of a special engagement
are willing to then go through the the
inconvenience in that context but if
people are unwilling to go through that
inconvenience in their own homes they're
not going to go through that
inconvenience just to watch a
five-minute YouTube video
then what and now now here's the thing
here's the thing is that the the answer
is phones so now this is this is the
funny bit is that the Future VR is the
cardboard now I'm not saying that it
specifically is Google cardboard but in
concept it is the card where there's a
bunch of devices similar to this that
are all out or coming out this one just
happens to be you know free if you can
get your hands on one but so you got
your phone you got your viewing device
and you put your phone into your viewing
device and close it up and then you take
it and you stick to your face and now
this is not necessarily a thing that you
want to be doing for very long because
this is kind of this is kind of weird
and kind of awkward and feels kind of
dumb hey what do we have what what
content do we have that people really
only want to engage with for a couple
minutes at a time now the great thing
about it is that you've got all the
phones that are coming out and they
already have accelerometers they already
have basically all of the technology
built into them in order to do a rough
you know head tracking kind of kind of
thing and so that marriage right there
between a fairly inexpensive headset and
you can get like I think the the Samsung
one is like 80 bucks or a hundred bucks
but it only works with Samsung phones it
works okay
and you can get other cheaper ones like
viewmaster makes ones it's about $30
it's plastic it's fairly it's it's
fairly lightweight it's more comfortable
in the cardboard and takes more phones
you do need a bigger phone but the thing
is is that so many people already have
these like it's already a device that
you own it's an expensive device but you
already own it and so really you're just
looking that on top of that you're
adding you know the cost of a relatively
inexpensive headset but it's like okay
even if you go for the Samsung one which
is you know like a hundred bucks
the the the rift is like six hundred
starts in like six hundred it's 800
Canadian the vive is $1,200 Canadian and
and yeah so that's the so that right
there is going to be kind of the thing
that I think is is ultimately going to
slowly very slowly break people into the
language of a spherical video and yeah
it's a complex situation right now as
there's a lot of other sort of weird
technical problems like so so spherical
video looks like just utter ass at
anything below 4k the the resolution
limitations of it are astounding and
that means so that creates a very
distinct problem again into our overall
content delivery pipeline where we're
talking about alright the best way of
kind of getting people used to this and
yes that's a spongebob sticker on the
back of my phone the best way of kind of
getting people used to this is phones
and that means streaming that
potentially means cellular streaming and
however in order for the content to even
be kind of like tolerable or to actually
feel good and not feel like it's just a
tech test you need 4k video yeah oh
that's actually I should actually say
that part of the reason why
this setup right here actually also
works is because of that resolution
limitations that for for a lot of
somatic reasons it is a lot more you're
a lot more tolerant of low quality low
resolution stuff when it's presented to
you in a context where you would expect
that and if you're putting your phone
into a chunk of cardboard with some
plastic into it and the end product
looks kind of okay but not stellar you
know if it's kind of low res and kind of
blocky and there's a lot of there's
there's a lot of you know compression
artifacts whatever whatever you know
you've got all of this as part of the
experience that's telling you like hey
don't don't take this super seriously
and and that can you know somatic
reasons not not semitic reasons somatic
reasons yeah it changes your
expectations and and makes you a lot
more tolerant Izzie of flaws in the end
product I mean and that goes for that
kind of goes for mobile in a lot of ways
to it it's like I mean even in gaming
people are saying like that's really
going to be kind of the thing it's going
to breakthroughs because it's like hey
if you're playing an iPhone game while
you're playing a mobile like a mobile
FPS the fact that it's going to look
like goldeneye is is just kind of
expected and say hey it's on your phone
what do you expect it's not going to
it's not going to look like doom it's
going to look like you'll do it's going
to look like the older dooms and not the
newer doom and and yeah
so that it changes your expectations of
how you're going to going to engage with
it yeah so needing 4k video
on the technical level the reason why
that is so if you think about it so you
have you're trying to cover a 360 by 360
by 360 degree field of view and if you
take a 1080 also it's so standard HD
video is 1080 it like tonight 1920 by
1080 so it's one thousand nine hundred
and eighty pixels wide 1080 tall now the
thing is is that actually a spherical
video is is a direct to one ratio so
it's actually a 1920 by 878 88 60 my my
brain mass is not so great at the moment
so I'm just going to do it 960 so 1920
by 960 would be your HD spherical video
so you have you've got basically 2,000
pixels in order to cover 360 lateral
degrees of viewing and so
so each each degree of the arc only has
about five five pixels to it so your
actual forward forward view and now in
VR your angle of view is actually for a
spherical video your angle of view is is
pretty limited it's only about thirty
degrees now maybe a bit no not thirty
degrees so that's 70 degrees 60 70
degrees it's about 70 degrees and so 70
degrees at at five and a third pixels
per degree like you're only seeing about
three hundred and seventy and change
pixels so your your forward arc
resolution is worse than SV it's worse
than an SD television and so yeah so the
actual picture quality in front of you
is bad even if it's a good quality like
a good quality flat image looks awful
once you've stretched it out to a 360
degree viewable arc and so in order to
actually get it you know pretty good
like so that if you if you want to be
able to see like let's say you're you
actually expand it so it's like 90
degrees if you want to see 1080 at 90
degrees then so 1920 time you need a
lateral here you go
in order for every view to have the
quality of of HD video you need a
lateral resolution of 7680 you need 8k
you need an 8k resolution just under
just under 8k resolution in order to get
things actually looking to get any
angles like any given view to look as
good as 1080 video 1080 flat 1080 video
so so that's that's what we're talking
about when it's like okay well how do
you get how do you get spherical video
to look good it's like well what can
your computer put out and so 4k like
this is what I mean when I say 4k is
basically the starting point of where it
actually looks kind of you know
tolerable like it actually starts to
look okay and doesn't look like a tech
demo is that it's like alright 4k is
still half that 4k means that it's like
alright what is what was it I was just
going to do 960 it ends up being 960 so
it's still worse than 720 video
so even 4k any given field of view is
still worse than than 720 720 HD so like
the bottom metric for HD video so it's
like alright but I mean if you think
about it like 720 most of you right now
are probably actually even though
there's a stream @ 1080p on the metrics
that I've been looking at most of you
are only watching it at 720 and you know
but you think about it 720 is really
only taking up about you know it's it's
a okay chunk of your screen but when
it's your entire field of vision you
know yeah yeah so really we're we're
halfway there
yeah we're halfway there and this kind
of technology bird a bird this jibber
jabber is what I
an awful lot of my time talking about in
in my day job stuff and whenever I go to
conventions like all of my time at PAX
last year like almost all of my time at
PAX last year was spent jockey was like
dudes from Google about like hey so
let's talk about delivering spherical
video also and I haven't even gotten
into I haven't even gotten into talking
about the the distance between the body
and the and the virtual sphere that the
video is projected on the inside of yeah
so I can I can already feel my brain
just kind of going going haywire and
turning into into absolutely heated mush
I've been talking way too fast and thank
you way too hard and doing too much math
after doing too much doom and and not
sleeping well so I think at this point
I'm going to actually for real wrap it
up rather than going on another 15
minute rant about the resolution
limitations of spherical video actually
it's oh no I'm not going to sign up
because all of that stuff that I was
talking about with the resolution that
applies just as much to games as it does
to spiracle video now spherical video is
a little bit more demanding because of
the uncanny valley because you are
trying to present something
photorealistic whereas video games as
we're talking about with the fact it's
like something can look like Goldeneye
that you can use cartooning in order to
temper the audience's expectations of
closure so you're asking a little bit
more for them to initially achieve
closure but then it's easier to maintain
over time because things don't you know
you you can suspend your disbelief
because it's like oh that is just kind
of a symbolic representation of a person
and you don't need it to look like a
person but for high-end games you do
still have to deal with that limitation
that the less cartoon something is the
more it's trying you know the more
trying to actually look and feel like a
real space well you have that same
resolution image also with the added
complexity of the fact that the vast
majority of games is like virtual
reality games essentially need to be in
3d in order for people to in order for
people to really go with it now they do
also have the added there are
differences because if we want to get
into the nitty-gritty tech details then
we're also talking about the fact that a
video game is a rendered space and not a
projected space so because of that
you're not really dealing with the
limitations of this projection sphere
and so you're not really creating you
don't need to create an 8k fear around
the around the player but you are still
dealing with bad limitation of like okay
you're trying to catch any given field
of view and so you need in 1920 you want
you actually want a little bit more like
really if we're honest with ourselves
you want to push a little bit past so
you want to K per eye in order to give
you a little bit of overscan and
actually so you can start to fill in the
periphery so 2k per eye 60 FPS per eye
it's really demanding I mean that's why
these headsets like that's why it all
cost so much and that's why I like the
hardware to run it it's so much like
it's surprisingly demanding and it's
like you can tone it down you know but
you got to tone it down in the right
ways and you got to change the ways that
the the participant of the audience is
interacting with it so that they change
their expectations of what they're going
to get out of it and this is why it kind
of comes back to it's like hey it's
going to be mobile it's going to be
phones it's going to be short
experiences and that's how people are
going to get used to it and yeah
so how does uncanny valley apply to
resolution it well okay so it's sort of
a misapplication of the term the problem
is that the there isn't a term that
actually that I have found I haven't
found a term to properly describe a
disconnect between the the audience's
expectations of what a visual field
should look like and what is actually
being delivered so the reason why I say
uncanny valley the reason why I'm using
it in this context is because we're
ultimately talking so the uncanny valley
is a cork of the process of closure
where you know something the closer
something looks to human the easier it
is for you to achieve closure while
looking at it until it reaches a point
where it is so near to human but not
quite there the disagreement between
perception and expectation creates a
sharp downturn in the ability to achieve
closure because something enters an
honoree a stage of unreality and we
apply that specifically to human faces
and the reason we apply it specifically
to human faces is because that's where
it was first observed is that hey if you
make if you create like a latex human
face and the closer and closer it gets
to human the more and more human is like
hey it looks really really human and
then you hit a point where it's you know
also 3d graphics is you hit a point
where it's like hey that it's not
behaving right the skin isn't moving and
folding right and it's not you know it's
not reacting to light properly and it's
not you know the the way that the subtle
textures change in in skin as you're
watching someone so the blood flow and
the capillary action and pores and just
all of the little things about skin and
End and mouths and eyes aren't behaving
right and they're not
aimed with each other right in there
they're just doing something and that's
where we first noticed it was in that
context but the if you separate it from
the human face and you're just looking
at the the abstract process
psychological process of achieving
closure that Valley kind of always
exists it's just that the the less alive
something is the more resistance it is
to it that a not quite photorealistic
brick doesn't bother us because it's
just a brick and we don't care whereas a
not quite photorealistic face bugs up a
lot so the reason why I'm using in this
conduct is because when when you're
taking it and you're putting it into a
motion space like when it's when it's
not just a not quite photorealistic
brick when it's an environment that is
just off in some way that is that is
just not quite there when it's like
trying to be photo realistic but the
resolution is kind crap and it becomes
harder to actually properly engage with
it and we don't so we don't have a term
that distinguishes that from the
specific phenomenon related to faces so
that that's why I used it in in this
context is the jargon just doesn't exist
yet this is also new this is all so new
no cognitive cognitive dissonance is a
completely completely there like that's
its own thing and I wouldn't that's so
different a thing that I wouldn't I
wouldn't use that term in in this
context even though if you went lower
taste cognitive dissonance it is in fact
a dissonance between cognition and
expectation
so if aside from the fact that that is
already jargon a dissonance between
cognition and expectation is in fact
what it is so yeah yeah but like I said
like this is where we're pushing
boundaries and it's really cool and
exciting and I like being involved with
it but Oh 8k for a Hyatt 240 Hertz yeah
that would be actually a caper I at 240
Hertz would be overkill because the
limitation so the limitation of the
ability to perceive resolution is
attenuated by distance so if you're
talking about the distance between
yourself and a television screen like
the average viewing distance between
yourself and a television screen the
limit is around two and a half K for it
I shouldn't say for most people it's 2 K
that above 2000 pixels like above above
the 2k soft standard 1969 2 K is where
people rapidly drop off and their
ability to even perceive change it's
like progressive changes in pixel
density and there's a number of there's
a number of like tests that have been
done in this where it's like okay so
what they do so here's what we do here's
what here's what us like wacky wacky
video technicians do in order to like
demonstrate this kind of stuff so you
have you have an image that is you know
the maximum resolution of whatever your
output system can do so the the first
time I heard of this test so it was a 4k
it was a with a projector like it was a
cinema projector so it was a 4k cinema
projector and so what you do is you
start off with a grid that is
black and white squares so the intent so
just black and white square so so you
give you basically split it into just
quadrants giant you know black square
white square black you know white square
black square checkerboard pattern and
and then every couple of seconds or
every every second or so the the
resolution of the squares of the
checkerboard pattern cuts in you know
doubles so cuts in half basically the
things so it's you know it doubles every
time it goes in half every time and then
or or you can do it a little bit more
gradually but so basically the thing is
so you're watching it and you're
watching these the the checkerboard
pattern gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller and the question is
at what point does it cognitively stop
being a checkerboard pattern and simply
become a field of grey and and you test
this with different people and now
different people have different
limitations so this is the same thing
with the frame rate debated like how
what frame rate can you actually like
see the difference in and it comes down
to like a significant amount of it comes
down to training like people who are
used to looking at this stuff obviously
notice it so people so like fighter
pilots who are trained to have super
fast visual reactions can can see
differences that like you know 240 FPS
whereas the average person's a little
bit closer to like 60 50 30 for a lot of
people for a lot of people it's 30 30 40
yeah and so that's where you get into
all of these debates about about you
know temporal perception of resolution
but in this case so it's like so the
physical meant watching it actually like
the resolution actually increase in what
point does it turn into a gray field for
a lot of people it's actually around 2k
trained people you know up to up to 3k
almost no one actually gets up to 4k
resolution at a comfortable viewing
distance and can still see anything
other than a field of gray
and above that link if you wanted to go
up to 8k like No like it just stops like
your your body eventually physically
hits a limit where it can even perceive
the difference in increases in
resolution and yeah yeah so so 8k / I
would be overkill oh but that's of
course attenuated by viewing distance
because obviously if you get closer to
the screen so even though you're
watching a giant cinema screen at a
comfortable viewing distance it just
looks like a giant field of gray if you
then of course walk all the way up to
the screen you can see that it is in
fact still a checkerboard pattern so one
pixel by one pixel checkerboard pattern
but you're right up against the screen
so yeah yeah alright my brain is my
brains melting so I'm gonna I'm gonna
[Music]
thing I'm gonna sing and that thing is
going to be end of the stream and call
it there thanks everybody for coming and
hanging out I'm glad we could have some
great discussions about perception and
the death of the author and kitty-cats
and Roland Barthes and I'm trying to
remember one of the other things that we
actually like stops to have a discussion
about but I can't remember it anymore so
I'm just going to end it there for real
and for actually thanks everybody
have a good night